bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans le 7-8
sport l'émission consacrée comme vous le
savez à l'actualité sportive dans le
département tout de suite le sommaire de
votre émission séisme sur piste les
pistards de l'équipe de france
s'entraîne actuellement au vélodrome de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines en vue des
championnats du monde événement est
programmé du 2 au 6 mars à londres les
détails dans cette édition tennis l'open
de la verrière a débuté ce week-end au
parc philippe cousteau plus de 150
joueurs seront présents pendant les
trois semaines de compétition reportage
à suivre
basket ligne montrent un tommy c'est
gore 19 ans joue actuellement aux
etats-unis à cleveland est aujourd'hui
considéré comme un espoir du basket
français nous le recevrons en quelques
minutes au delà de son mentor corneille
et puis l'essentiel de l'actualité
sportive du département nous parlons
notamment des 6 heures de la colline
d'elancourt une compétition programmée
ce week-end à saint quentin en yvelines
les pistards de l'équipe de france
s'entraîne actuellement au vélodrome
national de saint quentin en yvelines
avec en ligne de mire les championnats
du monde une compétition glisse organisé
du 2 au 6 mars à londres les images sont
signés à mélanie poker les pistes 1 de
l'équipe de france repartent à la
conquête des podiums internationaux
après le trion défoncer au championnat
du monde 2015 à saint quentin en
yvelines
les cyclistes remettront en jeu leur
sept médailles obtenues pendant la
compétition mars prochain à londres en a
quand même de fortes de fortes chances
sans sans présager effectivement de
l'avenir mais on est l'une des nations
qui est forte sur la vitesse
individuelle
on a un titre sur le keirin on a un
titre sur la vitesse par équipes
donc ça c'est pour le sprint et puis sur
l'endurance
là aussi encore retravailler nos
fondamentaux sur la poursuite par
équipes et la poursuite individuelle
pour remporter les médailles les pistons
ont commencé leur phase de préparation
au vélodrome national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines une piste de
250 mètres semblable à celle de londres
donc on s'entraîne toutes les semaines
avec
un plan d'entraînement pour définir des
pics de forme et des pics de récup un
des périodes de récupération aussi et
donc c'est ça se passe comme ça et puis
ça se passe très bien ici dans un cadre
où travaille peut être très bien fait
les français auront à coeur de briller
pendant une championnat du monde tout en
gardant un oeil sur l'objectif
prioritaire de la saison et jeux
olympiques de rio l'été prochain c'est
le fil rouge de la carrière des ce2 tout
sportif donc c'est clair que les
sprinteurs blancs dans la tête depuis
déjà deux olympiques de londres du nom
tous ils sont ou seront revanchards
après avoir terminé deux fois avec deux
médailles d'argent
on a fixé six médailles
dont 4 espérés en or ça c'est le niveau
minimum parce qu'on a des talents parce
qu'on a des vrais champions et puis le
travail qui est engagée quand même
depuis depuis quelques mois commence
petit à petit à les faire avancer
de toute façon on va pas aux jeux
olympiques pour faire deuxième un moment
donné et lé profil qu'on a sont tout à
fait capables en termes de capacité
d'expérience à pouvoir aller chercher
cette médaille d'or l'année 2016 sera
t-elle placée sous le signe de la
victoire pour l'équipe de france de
piste la réponse à la fin des jeux
olympiques le 21 août prochain
l'une des têtes d'affiché des
championnats du monde de londres sera
une nouvelle fois mlle pistarde équipe
de france françois pervis ligne montant
avec cinq titres mondiaux aura fait ces
deux dernières années fait figure
d'épouvantail
nous l'avons rencontré nous sommes avec
lui ni monter un françois pervis
champion du monde du keirin champion du
monde du kilomètre et champion du monde
de vitesse individuelle et nous sommes à
quelques semaines des championnats du
monde qui se dérouleront à londres du 2
au 6 mai alors françois la question est
simple est-ce que vous êtes prêt pour
ces championnats du monde
pour l'instant je suis pas prêt il nous
reste encore quelques semaines avant
d'arriver aux championnats du monde donc
on est sûrs en phase de préparation et
d'entraînement intensif d'accord est là
pour l'instant du coup c'est quoi vos
entraînements votre quotidien
toujours deux entraînements par jour
entre coupé entre de la muscu de la
route ou des sprints sur la piste
très bientôt j'ai une coupe du monde
quand même ma dernière compétition avant
les championnats du monde et ce sera à
hong kong et ce sera ma sélection en
gros pour les championnats du monde et
ensuite pour les jeux olympiques donc
c'est une coupe du monde très importante
d où cette coupe du monde passe avant
les championnats du monde vous n'avez
pas du tout la tête pour l'instant aux
championnats du monde
non pour l'instant j'ai vraiment la tête
à la coupe du monde à hong kong
mi-janvier et donc pour moi c'est très
important parce que c'est ma sélection
c'est là quasiment là la seule chance
qui me restent pour sélectionner pour
bien figurer en vue des championnats du
monde et qui ensuite nous
sélectionnerons pour les jeux olympiques
et donc l'idée pour vous c'est vraiment
de prendre les compétitions pour les
compétitions parce que il va avoir les
jeux un avis qui vont arriver très
rapidement
oui puis il faut être qualifié pour le 2
1 il faut être qualifié voilà tout à
fait donc c'est pour ça que il faut
aller étape par étape marche par marche
donc la prochaine étape c'est la coupe
du monde devant kong est pour l'instant
j'ai la tête qu'à hong kong donc si vous
êtes qualifiés du coup à hong kong pour
ces championnats du monde
quels sont vos objectifs là bas ça sera
de la préparation pour en vue des jeux
olympiques où est ce que le but ce sera
de garder vos médailles que vous avez
acquises ici à au vélodrome de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines
si je peux garder mes titres de champion
du monde tant mieux je vais pas me gêner
mais en tout cas ma tête sera plutôt à
rio parce qu'on s'est rendu compte qu'on
pouvait pas être au top de la forme au
mois de mars est au top de la forme au
mois d'août donc à la chapelle du monde
on va y aller sans trop d'ambitions sans
trop de grandes ambitions parce qu'il
faudra rester frais frais et dispos
mentalement et physiquement pour les
championnats du pour les jeux olympiques
donc ce championnat du monde
on va mal malheureusement les prendre
comme ils viennent
par contre c'est que vous êtes un
compétiteur avant tout je pense pas que
vous y alliez à londres juste pour
regarder les autres gagner non c'est
vrai j'ai pas envie de perdre ce bas mot
ce beau maillot là donc j'ai envie de
garder donc comme j'ai dit je vais pas
me gêner pour pour essayer de le garder
quelle que soit la discipline par contre
il ya de grandes chances que je ne fasse
pas le kilomètre parce que c'est plus
olympiques et je vais garder ma
fraîcheur physique pour les fps et voilà
une pour les épreuves
olympiques parce que peut-être que le
champion du monde serviront de dernière
sélection en vue des jeux olympiques
donc c'est important que je me focalise
simplement seulement sur les épreuves
olympiques
vous êtes actuellement peut-être le
meilleur sprinteur sur le keirin
c'est votre épreuve phare on voulait pas
la perdre cette course
non mais oui c'est vrai c'est vrai ça
fait deux années de suite que je suis
champion du monde
en curling ça c'est très peu vu jara
délais
l'historique des champions du monde en
kering
ces vingt trente dernières années il ya
qu un coureur qui a réussi à gagner une
deuxième fois de suite ce titre de
champion du monde de keirin
donc moi là je suis pour une deuxième
fois donc pourquoi pas donc là vous
allez rentrer dans l'histoire jamais
deux sans trois voilà encore une
nouvelle fois essayé de rentrer dans
l'histoire après mais mon triplé
historique en 2014 à cali et mes deux
records du monde
pourquoi pas avec le premier qui gagne
trois titres de champion du monde de
keirin d'affilée et surtout maintenant
vous avez pris goût à la victoire
c'est vrai c'est vrai que les 17
dernières épreuves que j'ai fait aux
championnats du monde ces deux dernières
années j'en ai gagné 6 forcément
forcément oui je suis pris goût à la
victoire et faut que ça continue
il ya une attente aussi de la part du
public français maintenant qui vous
connaît voilà il ya eu votre votre
double page votre une sur le quotidien
l'équipe
vous voulez vous voulez pas les décevoir
non c'est vrai et puis j'ai des
partenaires aussi qui me font confiance
et auxquels je dois je dois remercier
aussi en gagnant c'est important donc il
faut aussi qu'ils comprennent que les
jeux olympiques cette année c'est
vraiment l'événement phare de l'année et
que on peut pas courir tous les lièvres
à la fois mais je pense que ça tout le
monde aura compris mais en tout cas je
vais pas aux championnats du monde en
traînant des pieds
j'y vais vraiment aussi pour gagner mais
avec la forme du moment qui ne sera pas
forcément une forme d'un championnat du
monde habituellement mais un petit port
de ça parce qu'il faut garder il faut en
garder sous le pied pour les jeux
olympiques vous aviez bien préparer les
championnats du monde juste avant les jo
et finalement un gigot ça ne s'est pas
concrétisé c'est peut-être ça le piège
aussi cette année justement ce piège-là
a été effectué
en 2008 aux derniers jeux en 2012 en
2012 aux derniers jeux à londres et en
2008 aussi aux jeux de pékin
donc maintenant s'est rendu compte de ça
donc c'est pour ça que l'échappée a du
moins là on les prend pu plus ou moins
comme comme ils viennent parce qu'on n'a
pas le choix si on veut être performant
est à 100% rio mois d'août on peut pas
être déjà 100 % au mois de mars
donc on essaie d'apprendre de nos
erreurs et on va essayer d'être
peut-être performant mais sans plus pour
les championnats du monde dans ses puces
une phase de préparation peut-être un
aux entraînements part aux entraînements
c'est comme les titres de champion du
monde ce n'est pas à négliger
moi j'ai mis douze ans avant d'avoir mon
premier titre de champion du monde donc
je peux pas dénigrer un titre de
champion du monde
mais cette année c'est sûr que puisqu'il
ya un événement qui est
planétaire qui est au dessus avec les
jeux olympiques à l'échappée à du monde
forcément un petit peu moins de valeur
cette année et on fait en conséquence
donc la conséquence fait que les
championnats du monde cette année on va
y aller on va essayer de gagner mais on
met pas toutes nos billes pour échapper
à du monde et pour vous ça représente
quoi
des jeux olympiques ça représente le
graal à quand les champions olympiques
on change
cc interplanétaire c'est c'est quasiment
indescriptible parce que là là ça me
fait sortir de l'anonymat pour un sport
comme le mien qui est pas forcément très
connus et puis on n'est pas connue que
seulement des cyclistes dans le monde
entier on est connu de toute la
population mondiale quand tu es champion
olympique et tu pas sur toutes les télés
du monde
et personnellement moi c'est je sais pas
je vis pas dans le regard des gens mais
pour mes partenaires c'est très
important
puis pour en avoir de nouveau et puis
aussi parce que sportivement parlant
les jeux olympiques c'est
c'est ce qui fait arriver tous les
sportifs de haut niveau c'est le graal
c'est le la compétition ultime à gagner
si on vous avait dit il ya 15 ans que
vous soyez peut-être à la limite de
gagner une médaille d'or olympique
vous l'auriez cru ou pas du tout
peut-être oui parce qu'en 15 ans je me
suis dit je me dis peut-être qu'il ya 15
ans bon voila j'ai 15 ans d'entraînement
peut-être que je progresse et puis ça
peut être ça peut être possible
aujourd'hui celle là donc je compte pas
je compte pas passer à côté et en tout
cas l'encadrement le staff fait tout
pour que tous les cyclistes sur piste
soit au top pour ces jeux olympiques
oui on a on a beaucoup de réflexions se
remet en question la fédération mais les
moyens qu'il faut a fait son possible et
nous à être les entraîneurs et le staff
le médical les kinés
les osthéos être l'hydrothérapie et tous
on se donne vraiment les moyens de
réussir et on fait de notre mieux pour
pour donner à 100% pour être champion
olympique
donc vous n'avez pas les excuses il
faudra bien alors c'est ça il faut
emmener l'or mais comme on dit c'est
le nerf de la guerre c'est l'argent et
quant au manque d'argent on peut pas
développer
on peut pas aller dans le développement
extrême par exemple du matériel des
casques des combinaisons donc on est
aussi limité quand même par rapport à au
budget que la fédération a mais en tout
cas on essaye de bien utiliser ce budget
on se donne on se donne à fond pour pour
y arriver donc moi je suis plus du genre
à me trouver des excuses mais
en tout cas on fait avec nos moyens et
on se donne à fond pour pour rien
regretter donc en tout cas on vous
souhaite de remporter cette médaille
d'or merci beaucoup françois pervis
après une large page cycliste pour passe
au tennis
le 13e open de tennis de la verrière a
débuté ce week-end au parc philippe
cousteau cette année plus de 150 joueurs
vont s'affronter jusqu'au 31 janvier les
images sont signés patrick jacques de
dixmude
c'est l'un des temps forts de ce début
d'année pour le sport saint quentinois
le 13e open de tennis de la verrière
s'est ouvert ce week-end au parc
philippe cousteau pour cette édition
2016 150 joueurs venus principalement de
la ville nouvelle se sont inscrits pour
participer à la compétition
c'est souvent la seconde série qui
viennent marquer des points pour être
pour être prof de tennis il faut
justement être seconde série et les
les enfin les jeunes qui veulent qu'ils
souhaitent être professionnel finalement
il essaie de marquer des points en début
de saison donc c'est là du début de
saison au mois de janvier
c'est bon à prendre le tableau masculin
compte 100 joueurs âgés de 15 à 69 ans
chez les dames une cinquantaine de jeux
se sont inscrits au tournoi objectifs de
chaque participant soulever la coupe le
dimanche 31 janvier après une victoire
en finale
on ne sait pas pour faire bien sûr on le
fait pour essayer d'améliorer un petit
peu classement et qui pour voir un petit
peu aussi tuer mais plutôt pour s'amuser
un petit peu aussi d'aller plus loin
possible mais je ne sais même pas en
fait les filles contre qui joue je
connais même pas leur classement donc
juste je regarde pas et je viens jouer
et à appliquer les conseils que j'ai vu
pendant tous les cours et les
entraînements pour ce rendez vous un
seul juge arbitre officie pendant le
tournoi le fair-play donc mise à
l'honneur les joueurs sautent aux
arbitres c'est la raison pour laquelle
on demande aux joueurs effectivement
d'avoir d'être sportifs de si la balle
est faute ou doit il ya jugement
on n'a juste pas sûr d'être faudra donc
on remet de balle voyez c'est ces deux
bonnes je fais confiance pas il ya la
lentille jeu devrait pas exister
en semaine les matchs sont programmés de
18 à 22 heures le week-end les premiers
échanges du but à 9 heures et se
terminent à 20 heures
on continue ce magazine par du basket
thomis et gorges ni mon teint de 19 ans
ancien meneur de l'entente le
chesnay-versailles joue actuellement au
spyer instit shoot une école implantée à
cleveland été repérés l'été dernier par
des recruteurs américains lors d'un camp
d'entraînement aux états unis nous avons
la chance de recevoir sur ce plateau
thomis et gore et son mentor quand les
créateurs du sib ici et les le camp qui
a permis à tomic d'être sélectionné
bonsoir alors tommy vous êtes revenu
pour les vacances de noël
ici en france est-ce que ça fait du bien
tout simplement de recharger les
batteries en famille bah oui c'est sûr
puisque avec maintenant je revois la
famille les amis
donc c'est sûr que ça fait du bien je
peux revoir quand mais aussi je crois un
peu tout le monde
on connaît ses heures ça fait du bien
avant de repartir bientôt et
l'intégration aux états unis a été
plutôt facile ou compliqué ces quelques
semaines
c'est à dire ce que haut niveau au
niveau des entraînements enfin au niveau
de la langue aussi il après les joueurs
là-bas sont assez sont assez amical donc
ils sont ils m'ont bien l'intégrer donc
j'ai pu j'ai pu bien m'adapter aux au
fil du temps justement cette barrière de
la langue n'est pas trop compliqué à
gérer quand quand on joue au basket pour
se faire comprendre de ses coéquipiers
par exemple mais après dans le contexte
basket ça va c'est pas c'est pas très
compliqué vu que en france les on parle
souvent les mots qu'on utilise au basket
sont souvent en anglais donc comme
certains termes donc j'arrive
j'arrive au bout quoi comprendre
conseiller niveau basket ça il ya
beaucoup d'étrangers également d'autres
équipements vous n'êtes pas le seul
petit étrangers à part dans son coin
vous êtes plusieurs noms mais blizzard
nationalité mais il ya des turcs slovène
espagnol italien chinois il ya un peu de
tout corneille est-ce qu'il faut être
fort dans sa tête pour tenter ce type d'
aventure en tout cas quand on y va il
faut être préparé
enfin se dire qu'on y va pas par hasard
donc mentalement faut se dire qu'on a un
objectif on vient là bas en rien
l'objectif on sait très bien qu'on va
avoir des difficultés et les obstacles à
surmonter
on a la difficulté de l'as de la
solitude parce que se retrouve tout seul
là bas même s'il ya d'autres étrangers
qu'on n'est pas le seul étranger mais
quand même tous à la famille est loin
comme il l'a dit juste avant
donc faut être préparé mentalement c'est
ce qu'on avait essayé de faire à travers
le camp faire une préparation mentale
assez importante et le préparer aussi
pour justement pour affronter ces
difficultés
cette difficulté donc oui c'est
difficile mais quand la un objectif sans
tête et qu'on est prêt mentalement en
cire menteuse elle accueille justement
c'est le mental we collide oui on a mûri
sicile montalier on peut aller on n'a
pas de limites
vous vous faites un peu le dos rond là
c'est ça en ce moment justement tommy
aux états unis fait un peu le dos rond
vous voyez un petit peu comment ça se
passe et c'est peut-être justement que
vous
vous allez intégrer votre place en tant
que titulaire à part entière dont c'est
le but c'est de prendre la place des
joueurs qui étaient là avant moi enfin
des joueurs qui sont plus forts que moi
actuellement
donc moi mon but c'est de progresser le
maximum possible pour ensuite avoir une
place importante dans l'équipe
de quoi souffre et a confiance a pour
l'instant où c'est un petit peu
compliqué c'est pas que je ne fais pas
confiance ou enfin il me donne quand
même vous faire entrer sur le terrain
c'est pour c'est plutôt pour défendre
parce que j'ai voulu montrer directement
que j'aimais défendre j'ai que je
pouvais défendre donc souvent quand
quand il ya des joueurs que certains
arrivent pas à tenir
souvent je rentre sur le terrain pour
pour essayer de les tenir
justement là on voit en ce moment même
et on va voir l'infographie qui va
apparaître justement à l'écran voilà
avec ce maillot là c'est avec ce maillot
là où j'ai eu tout un match du cool fm
joue en blanc ou en bleu on n'a pas
toujours le même numéro ça change et
vous tournez à combien de points par
match pour l'instant vous avez des
statistiques peuvent ou pas du tout pour
l'instant pas de poste duster d'accord
c'est plutôt les matches amicaux
oui voilà que vous avez respect ces deux
matches amicaux passait pas sous forme
de championnat et le niveau est aussi
bon qu'on le dit aux états unis où il
est peut-être pas comme vous l'espériez
il est ce un très bon niveau après c'est
pas il ya c'est comme partout c'est pas
parce que souvent les gens france qu'ont
dit les états unis on pense directement
la nba et universités les joueurs qui
tout le monde des geeks mais a des
joueurs qui sont sont banales qui sont
pas forcément très fort mais il ya
beaucoup c'est vrai qu'il ya beaucoup de
bons joueurs mais à des joueurs comme en
france qui sont pas forcément très fort
donc et vous trouvez qu'il ya un gouffre
entre la france et les états unis où
finalement le gouffre et n'engageait
pour l'instant il ya une grosse
différence serait la france et les états
unis niveau au niveau mentalité ce que
aux entraînements ça s'est souvent soudé
ça qu'on voit qu'il ya un ou deux
joueurs qui sont pas dedans par exemple
qu'on va faire des
d entraînement assez physique bas tout
le monde les joueurs qui sont un peu
plus au dessus vent les encourager les
pousser vers l'avant alors qu'en france
c'est souvent chacun dans son coin moi
je veux réussir alors que la bassée
c'est plus + famille c'est plus tout le
monde s'aide donc c'est plutôt cool
quant à yves aussi la distance a commis
oui bien sûr bien sûr moi je le suis on
s'appelle assez régulièrement pour
savoir un petit peu comment ça il évolue
je pense que le plus difficile pour lui
actuellement c'est que depuis quelques
années qu'on a évolué ensemble notamment
avec maxime aura souverain feuilles
drague est il a toujours été l'un des
meilleurs joueurs de l'équipe donc set
c'était le pilier là il se retrouve dans
un contexte où déjà là lors d'un grand
ses plus rudes de la concurrence est
rude et il fait pas partie des meilleurs
joueurs forcément tout de suite
donc là il va falloir qui justement
qu'ils fassent un peu le dos rond qu'il
observe beaucoup qui travaillent dans
l'ombre de manière à pouvoir leur
prendre leur place d'ici quelques mois
ce que j'espère en tout cas
et quel est le programme pour la suite
c'est du coup tommy vous retourne aux
états unis là je dis oui
et du coup pareil la même chose vous
allez a recommencé l'entraînement tout
de suite dans l'immédiat directement dès
que j'arrive là-bas
enfin j'arrive le soir donc après judor
et le lendemain matin directement on
nous emmène après les entraînements
recueillir commandes et cette aventure
vous donne envie de devenir basketteur
professionnel ça vous donne encore plus
envie d'être là ulrich kater pas ce que
c'est c'est vraiment une belle
expérience
parce que justement grâce grâce à cornet
j'ai aussi biselx et j'ai pu j'ai pu
aller jouer aux états unis où j'y
croyais pas trop mais maintenant je peux
donc ça me donne vraiment envie de
d'aller encore plus loin
enfin d'attendre d'atteindre le niveau
le meilleur niveau que je puisse vous
est fixé une deadline peut-être pour
passer professionnel
non pas du tout pour moi il y en a pas
pour moi pour moi n'importe quel âge on
peut on sait pas ce qui peut arriver par
exemple via des souvent des jeux à 1 ghz
à 23 à 24 ans c'est fini mais moi pour
moi je me dis que n'importe quel âge on
peut peut intriguer percée il en a les
capacités
en tout cas il va travailler pour
s'initier le rôle du syli s'élève à être
deux
de la compagnie maintenant dans sa
formation il est au début de sa
formation aux états unis sauf le camp
qui a permis à termi d'être opéré c'est
ça et maintenant qu'il aux etats unis
c'est le début de sa formation
donc il faut qu'on le suive qui qu'on le
mette dans d'autres dans d'autres
dispositions pour éventuellement qu'il y
arrive ce que je l'espère en tout cas
ils subissent il est aussi lui espéré on
va l'accompagner
on va terminer par une question simple
quel est votre plus grand rêve tommy ça
serait dur nba oui comme tout basketteur
je pense donc enfin oui jouer
professionnel le port on vous le
souhaite en tout cas merci à tous les
espaces et sur ce plateau donc c'était
un plaisir de vous recevoir dans cette
émission continuera à vous suivre un
tommy à aux états unis on va
régulièrement des informations sur vous
merci à vous on peut zoomer à présent
sur les 6 heures de la colline à des
encours la première édition des 6 heures
de la colline d'elancourt était
programmé ce dimanche soixante coureurs
ont participé à cette course à pied non
officiel organisé par la plateforme
internet qui courent où le principe
chaque participant devait réaliser le
plus de tours possibles en six heures
romain respini à pour le montage de la
boue des températures plutôt fraîches et
les bonzes ardue les conditions extrêmes
n'ont pas découragé ces mordus de course
à pied ce dimanche 10 janvier ils
étaient une soixantaine à participer à
la première édition des 6 heures de la
colline d'elancourt une compétition non
officielle organisée via la plateforme
communautaire acquis qu on compte les
tours et avec le nombre de tours on
saura combien de dénivelé chaque
participant aura parcouru mais c'est
vraiment pour le fun a absolument pas de
classement officiel après parmi les gens
que vous avez eue passé il y en a qui
courent plus vite que d'autres
on a quelques petits champions on va
dire voir d'un bon champion même donc je
pense que vont finir avec certainement
plus de tours que les autres mais c'est
pas grave ça fait partie des fans c'est
ils sont là pour ça et union et nous on
est là pour ça mais on est absolument
pas de compétition chaque tour mesure 1
4 km avec 125 mètres de dénivelé un
tracé pensé spécialement pour les
experts en course à pied
on est des trailer alors les très belles
montagnes problème c'est que dans les
yvelines il a pas beaucoup il n'y a pas
beaucoup de dénivelés donc du coup ici
c'est pas mal parce que sur une distance
assez courte
on peut réussir à faire des petits
dénivelés sympa là en l'occurrence
sur une dizaine de kilomètres de mémoire
sur 14 kilomètres on arrive à cumuler
1200 mètres de dénivelé ce qui est pas
mal
c'est pas les alpes mais presque
aujourd'hui s'est rendue difficile à
cause de la boue donc on a même
positionné des cordes à certains
endroits pour faciliter la montée les
descentes sont très techniques
compétition également pour la bonne
cause la plupart des participants a fait
des dons en faveur de l'association
aliénor structure qui forme des chiens
guides pour les non voyants
c'est au bon vouloir de chacun tout
simplement en sentant concernée ou moi
la finalité était malgré tout se
retrouver entre coureurs avant la
participation à cette association
au regard du succès rencontré pour cette
grande première une deuxième édition
pourrait être organisée dans les
prochains mois on passe à présent
l'essentiel des résultats du week-end
on commence à trub rick résultats par le
dakar 2016 deux ym-ywha sont
actuellement en course pour ce rallye
raid jambes yark jean pierre garcin de
montesson est actuellement la troisième
place 35e place du classement après
quatre étapes à 2 heures 47 minutes et
20 secondes du leader sébastien loeb de
son côté jean-philippe thériault de la
celle saint cloud et 58e de la
compétition à plus de cinq heures des
leaders et de concurrents évinois ont
pour objectif de terminer la course
on passe au rugby le sky n'en finit plus
de gagner les hommes coachés par thomas
payan enregistré une nouvelle victoire à
l'extérieur sur le terrain de triel les
mureaux le score 27 à 10 pour les saint
quentinois
avec cette victoire le sky rugby reste
leader de cette poule 3 avec un bilan
parfait de dix victoires en dix matches
un sans faute qui leur permet de
conserver la tête du championnat avec 5
points d'avancé sur le 2e clairement on
reste dans le rugby mais on redescend
d'une division en première série mon
team automne a certainement perdu tout
espoir de monter les il monte un an
perdu 34 à 17 sur le terrain de
l'olympique connu mais rien une défaite
lourde de conséquence les joueurs de
seine et marne comptent désormais dix
points d'avancé sur les yvelinois
montigny reste tout de même solidement
ancré à la troisième place du classement
et peut toujours vissé à la deuxième
place
un mot de football à présent en division
excellence se mord pas continue sa
formidable remontée au classement
les mots repasser en battue ce week-end
à domicile poissy sur le score de 4 buts
à 2 en match en retard conséquence et
saint quentinois pointe désormais à la
5e place du classement avec 24 points
unité du podium on joue également en
nationale 3 de basket trap est sur une
très bonne dynamique les trappistes se
sont imposés 64 à 37 sur le terrain de
malakoff lors de la 11e journée les
hommes de mustapha el hafidi en
remporter ce match grâce à leur défense
de fer
au classement le fc trappes remonte à la
sixième place du championnat avec cette
deuxième victoire en trois matches
disputés
on termine cette rubrique résultats par
du handball promu cette année en
nationale une montigny a enregistré une
nouvelle défaite à l'extérieur sur le
terrain de fleury loiret lors de la 11e
journée
une contre-performance qui risque de
peser lourd dans la balance en fin de
saison
les îles lointaines sont désormais avant
dernière de la poule une avec 16 points
engrangés c'est la fin de 7,8 sport
merci d'avoir suivi on se retrouve lundi
prochain pour un nouveau magazine très
belle soirée sur tv fil 78